hi I'm Erik Bosse as we look ahead to
this year of all the questions left to
be answered in the upcoming films of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe 102 know is
how did Nick Fury lose his eye I know
it's employed to ask and honestly I'm
kind of intimidated to ask Nick Fury
anything in the eye is obviously a sore
subject last time I trusted someone I
lost you know favorite clip you're gonna
see it alot this video Avengers in game
is coming out in April but before that
Captain Marvel was coming it's set in
the distant past in the 1990s a time
when Nick Fury still had two functioning
eyes so we can assume that this movie
will finally reveal how he lost it and I
think right now we might already have
enough clues to pieced it together I'm
gonna take a shot at it and spoiler
warning in case I'm right and I ruin
your life
okay let's break down what we know
starting with well let's play it again
Devon last time I trusted someone I lost
an eye yes fury was snapping a cap and
kept America the Winter Soldier over
whether superheroes moral codes could be
trusted and whether Fury's confidence in
the system of shield was misplaced
this was the one moment from fury that
hinted at how his eye was injured it was
a result of misplaced trust in someone
that already was a step away from pure
ease origin in the Marvel comics in
which he lost his eye from shrapnel
while serving in World War two so whom
did fury mistakenly trust the most
obvious answer would be a villain from
Captain Marvel Talos Ben Mendelsohn's
character Talos is actually a scroll a
shape-shifter disguising himself as a
human and his infiltrated shield is
currently serving as Fury's boss Fury
would have presumably trusted Talos and
then maybe he'll learn the truth leading
to a nasty right that results in Fury
losing his eye but part of me feels like
it wouldn't be that simple like in the
days before the Avengers endgame trailer
took over my life I had about 72 hours
or so to obsess over the Captain Marvel
trailer and the big theory I had coming
out of that trailer is that o is not
what it seems to be with that movie the
trailers have been edited together
cryptically enough to make me think that
carol danvers memories could have been
false implanted ones brainwashing her
into thinking that the scroll are more
evil than they really are and the Kree
are more heroic than they really are I'm
just saying that it's possible that
Talos and the other scroll that have
infiltrated Earth's government
institutions might actually be more of a
peacekeeping force trying to strengthen
Earth's security to prevent the danger
militaristic Cree from invading them so
that leads me to another possible
explanation of which seemingly
trustworthy figure could have taken Nick
Fury's eye Carol Danvers Danvers does
appear to have Fury's trust and if that
brainwashed in theory ends up being true
maybe she possesses some Manchurian
Candidate type trigger that will cause
her to switch in murder mode and attack
fury but in the marvel prelude comic
fury had some nice words for Captain
Marvel hinting to Maria Hill that at
least one hero existed out there who
would never let you down
that's not something you would say about
someone who took your eye now one thing
I should also point out fury might
already be in the process of losing his
eyes like a number of the photos and
shots have shown Fury with a cut over
his eye but he still has the eye it's
still working like maybe this wound was
caused in a particular way like with
some slow-moving alien toxin like
scroller Kree poison that gradually
infects his I know if you compare this
fairly modest cut with the way his eye
and cheek looked when he lists his patch
in the Winter Soldier I don't know how
that could lead to this honestly I
wouldn't be surprised if the Captain
Marvel movie toys with us like maybe
he's showing Nick Fury get into a bunch
of close calls with his eye but none of
them into be the big injury that takes
it out like fury cuts his eye on an
icicle that was a close one the
chopstick flies out of his hand
yikes I know that bullet dodged gotta be
more careful an evil scroll posing as a
LASIK surgeon Fury's eyes in the
crosshairs but then the surgeon gets a
heart attack and drops dead that one was
on me oh no I just think that would make
it really fun if it ends up being
something unexpected and seemingly
harmless that ends up injuring his eye
like a baby you always trust the baby
not to hurt you until they spit up in
your eye is that your last time holding
a baby Nick last time yeah that's how
but if you watch the Captain Marvel
trailer closely you could definitely see
Fury show someone or something a lot of
trust what's your name aha the cat you
can never trust cats
that's scarring on Fury's cheek
definitely it looks like three kitty cat
claws so why would Carol Danvers cat
attack fury
well it could be because it's not a cat
in the movie the cat seems to have the
name goose which is of course a Top Gun
reference but in the comics Carol
Danvers cat is named chewy and rocket
racoon Discoverer
that it's not a cat at all it's actually
an alien race called a fleur kin they
look a lot like cats from Earth but
they're not and when things rocket
raccoons nuts for trying to kill it but
he's right this thing lays eggs and its
mouth is a bunch of terrifying tentacles
that pop out and other nested in our
mouths with sharp fangs lurkers are
nasty it's like the freaking thing from
the thing interestingly firkins can
carry pocket dimensions like they can
store entire universes within their
mouths honestly kind of like that
collared dimension from the cat men in
black on Orion's belt these pocket
dimensions allow them to store and call
upon all kinds of crap at will and they
can travel instantaneously using the
interdimensional connections within
their bodies it's just a really gross
process they're also extremely smart
they can understand human conversation
and look again at that cat that fury
pets when he tries to look at its collar
notice how the cat puts his paw on
Fury's hand pushes it down yes cats do
this sometimes this move just looks
suspicious it's like this cat it's
trying to hide something like maybe he
doesn't want fury to look in his mouth
and cap tomorrow as a movie is
definitely hinting at something
nefarious with this cat like remember in
the very first poster of the movie they
hid that cat in the shadows of the frame
like why do that why you being so sneaky
goose what are you hiding so I'm just
saying maybe this cat will reveal itself
as a flirt gain and suddenly attack fury
clawing his eye out dragging him along
from dimension to dimension
until finally fury man just to kill the
damn thing yeah
fury definitely wouldn't be much of a
cat person after that and maybe that's
why thick fear he hasn't talked about
this that much the myth is so much more
threatening than saying a kitty
scratched me even if this creature is so
much more than a kitty instead fury can
just lightly allude to some badass
mystery origin and use it to scare
people into silence your your not gonna
show it oh here last time I trusted
someone I lost an eye yeah it never gets
old alright comment down below with your
thoughts on this theory and follow new
rock stars on twitter at new rock stars
and me on twitter and instagram @ EF us
and subscribe to new rock stars for
theories and breakdowns of everything
Marvel related and hopefully a future
breakdown of Sam Jackson yelling at the
cat